ouverte je vous propose de faire une
découverte participative très
intéressante avec jérémy demay qui nous
a rejoint et ça ça fait toujours plaisir
bienvenue jérémy bonjour jean pascal
merci d'être là cette semaine vous êtes
intéressé à la solidarité autour des
monuments pour leur sauvegarde pour leur
réhabilitation ou tout simplement aussi
pour leur entretien finalement oui alors
ça on en trouve un petit peu partout
pour les espaces verts pour des petits
travaux de maçonnerie finalement les
chantiers solidaires mais là je voulais
vraiment plus m'intéresser à ces
chantiers qui permettent à des monuments
de tout simplement tenir debout
noche ce qui est quand même assez
pratique oui c'est plutôt pas mal on en
voit un peu partout en bourgogne
france-comté moi j'ai entendu dire
qu'ils avaient par exemple la muraille
sud devait geler
oui tout à fait qui a pu être refaite en
grande partie grâce à des chantiers
solidaires mais il y avait aussi château
de rochefort du côté d'avenir en
montagne avait aussi du côté de d'ornans
le château de ça c'est enfin il n'a
vraiment partout dans les huit
départements de la région donc faire le
listing ce serait dur et jusqu'au soir 3
mais je crois qu'on n'a pas forcément le
temps donc je me suis axée surtout sur
le château desbordes à urzy parce que en
fait il réunit les trois aspects
finalement qu'on peut dégager des
chantiers solidaires
j'ai entendu dire que du côté du riz
justement on trouvait du logement
partager ça oui ça c'était ma dernière
chronique vous allez dire musique tout
en fixer sur zone
[Musique]
non en fait il faut savoir que cette
commune est riche patrimoine historique
alors le logement solidaire c'était dans
un ancien moulin qui fabriquait des
clous pour l'independent royal donc
c'est un héritage industriel mais là le
château desbordes c'est vraiment
l'histoire de ce village fait il est il
a été construit en deux fois il a été
détruit pendant la guerre de cent ans
mais il a été aussi pillé
alors non pas par une guerre non pas
pendant une révolution non il était
pliée à la fin du 20e siècle par un de
ses anciens propriétaires
il a tout pris 1 il a laissé que les
montants des cheminées il a même arraché
le parquet il a même pris les mangeoires
en pierre d
des écuries royales donc voilà on voit
des photos là le avant après dans ce
chantier ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils sont partis d'eux ça vraiment les
murs à l'extérieur était jolie à
l'intérieur ça ressemblait beaucoup à ça
ici on était dans les anciennes écuries
donc bien les ont beaucoup travaillé
beaucoup travaillé pour en faire une
salle de réception une salle de
restaurant et voilà maintenant ce que ça
donne donc c'était vraiment l'avant la
presse sur ce chantier et on le voit ça
permet aussi de trouver des sources de
financement autres notamment avec une
chambre d'hôte un restaurant des salles
de réception
ce qui permet d'essayer de trouver un
petit peu pas mal de dos tombe de
financement que le bénévolat c'est parce
que vous en pensez cyril et romaric mais
on a bien vu le avant après sur la salle
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
l'école à un objet déco est ce que
touche à taux finalement a eu droit à la
même cure de jouvence jérémy en très
très grande partie en très grande partie
parce que ben voilà le château il
domaine est assez vaste donc ça a touché
à la fois les les jardins mais aussi on
le voit à l'intérieur donc là c'est la
partie écuries mais il ya aussi la
partie habitation a tant que tel qui
était dans le même état qu on a vu tout
à l'heure sur la photo de l'avant donc
là ici on voit l'entretien des jardins
et des murailles et donc voilà c'est
grâce à une association de bénévoles
d'amoureux bon bien des mais évidemment
il ya aussi les propriétaires du château
qui se mobilisent tous ensemble pour
tenter de sauver ce château comprend
bien qu'ils ont eu des des bras et des
bonnes volontés on le voit d'ailleurs
ici il ya plein de monde ni même un
chien qui a participé de plusieurs
chiens un mail vous avez l'oeil mais
plus sérieusement il faut payer le
matériel quand même c'est un joli
d'avoir les bénévoles mais il faut quand
même de l'argent pour avoir le matériel
et bien c'est justement là tout
l'intérêt de ce type d'opération ce que
effectivement on a des bras avec des
bénévoles mais il faut de l'argent
donc il ya des campagnes de lancement
participatif notamment pour sauver un
mur alors ce mur ici on le voit ici
c'est pas un mur anodin dans l'histoire
du château puisque c'est le mur en fait
qui permet de soutenir bien tout là tout
le
les jardins qui sont au dessus donc sans
ce mur on voit que le jardin va
s'effondrer ce mur à bouger à cause de
la sécheresse donc on voit que toute
l'année même avec des événements
extérieurs
eh bien ils sont obligés de se reprendre
en main et pour trouver d'autres sources
de financement ge d'expliquer tout à
l'heure il ya aussi les chambres d'hôtes
et donc le restaurant vous parlez de
financement participatif je crois qu'à
partir du 21 avril justement ils vont
lancer quelque chose de particulier
voilà justement pour sauver ce mur donc
on le voit ici ce mur qui avant deux ou
trois ans on voyait qu'ils commençaient
à se fragiliser n'y avait pas autant de
fissures de de crevasses des d'énormes
fracture finalement dans son mur si on
ne fait rien il va tomber s'ils tombent
le jardin va s'effondrer et après les
campagnes participatif qu'est ce qui se
passe finalement jérémy est bien et ce
qui se passe c'est que ça permet
justement de pouvoir maintenir ce
château de pouvoir l'entretenir de
pouvoir faire tout simplement qui bat
qu'ils puissent continuer à passer le
temps donc ça c'est absolument
nécessaire et plusieurs sites en en
profiter un chenil franchement très je
crois qu'il ya la voir dans le doubs si
je me trompe pas oui alors ça c'est
grâce au loto du patrimoine savès avait
été annoncée par le gouvernement et un
rennais par stéphane bern
donc il y avait le lavoir à foucherans
mes yeux pleins de deux piliers de
l'islam aussi l'auteur du patrimoine
comme au lieu de faire justement les
entreprises siens qui participent les
entreprises le mécénat d'entreprise on
l'oublié assez souvent mais vu que c'est
des souvent gérés par des associations
ou bien des entreprises peuvent faire
des dons en plus c'est souvent
défiscalisée ça leur permet de faire de
la pub donc c'est pas négligeable
et voilà donc là ça n'a rien à voir avec
le château des bandits mais j'imagine
non pas du tout pas du tout c'est
peut-être un mariage participent été
fabriquées c'est par exemple sur des
chantiers participatifs en bourgogne
france-comté la photo je sais pas si
vous l'avez tous vu assez vite mais il
faudrait quand même qu'on identifie ce
couple de jeunes mariés pour qu'on leur
fait quand même tous nos voeux de
bonheur peut-être qu'ils sont partis ce
mariage au château des ventes puisqu'il
permet de recevoir aussi des réceptions
justement pour
justement c'est un petit peu
[Musique]